les travailleurs sont au rendez vous et
les fraises aussi la saison s'annonce
bonne chez bélisle un des plus grands
producteurs au québec acq la chaleur
qu'on a eu pour le plus gros dos la
frette impôts gorgée d'eau est vraiment
tout ce qui est très très élevé d'aller
aux fruits succulents la console grâce
au temps chaud ce printemps la
croissance des fraises est en avance de
deux semaines sur le calendrier régulier
mais une fois les fleurs sortie c'est un
casse tête si le mercure descend sous
zéro si elle gèle il n'y aura pas de
fruits en un système par aspersion
depuis le début de l'année louis bélisle
a dû arroser ses chants une dizaine de
fois pour garder ses frais en vie les
producteurs au québec ce printemps ils
ont travaillé terriblement fabre sauver
le flanc parce qu à trois fouilles du
gel fota rouge toutes les nuits fauves
deux otages for muscle on estime que les
pertes causées par le gel sont de moins
de 10 % à l'échelle de la province
on n'aurait pas une année comme l'année
passée vont manquer truc le cube statham
ou retombent d'une année normale
ici aussi on voit de belles grappes qui
a déjà commencé à être formés
ceux qui n'ont pas de système
d'irrigation comme le producteur de
bleuets raphaël gauchers sont plus
vulnérables
ces plans ont été victimes du gel mais
rien de trop dramatique
aucun dessus se rapproprier 5 à 10%
selon les régions d'al cher on a eu des
pertes qui sont assez minimes
comparativement à d'autres producteurs
au saguenay-lac-saint-jean par exemple
les producteurs envisagent des pertes de
25 à 75% en raison du gel
certains ont aussi été durement touchée
en estrie dans lanaudière guettant
beaulieu a dû partir s'est jusqu'alors
une fois cette saison pour protéger ces
bleuets contre le gel est survenu un
froid pas mal c'est vers la semaine
passée et vous dirais que je mange très
bien parce que
je regarde mes débuts et il n'y a
presque pas portes de marge
dieu allégations que j'ai fait il
s'attend à une bonne récolte cette année
mais jamais dans l'agriculture
c'est très bon produit mais s'ils
arrivent une graine au mois de juillet
il n'y a plus rien alors c'est difficile
de faire des prédictions dans ce métier
c'est presque toujours la météo qui a le
dernier mot ici olivier bachand et radio
canada
c'est mélanie